- Welcome back.
This is the third panel.
I'm Eve Blau, the moderator
of the third panel.
And this panel is about the
planned and the unplanned.
So the concern of
this panel is with
the complex and
intertwined relationship
between planned and
unplanned processes
of urban environments--
in urban environments, actually.
And the central
question that will
be addressed by the panelists--
from different
disciplinary perspectives,
from different geographies
and professional practices--
is basically, what
is that relationship,
and what should it be?
Now I want to say a few
words just about the topic,
and frame the
session a little bit.
It's very often the
case, as we all know,
that official city plans are
not realized in their proposed
forms.
Plans are, by definition,
projective and propositional.
They tend to be
aspirational, no matter
their claims to pragmatism.
And they are always political
and always contested,
as we saw in the last panel.
In order to be realized,
therefore, they
require some buy in
from stakeholders.
But they also have to adapt
to realities on the ground,
including informal practices
and patterns of human behavior
that are deeply embedded in
the social and built fabric
of urban environments.
As a result, plan
change inevitably
produces unanticipated outcomes.
So what is the relationship
between the planned
and the unplanned?
In the early 20th century, when
planning, or town planning,
as it was called
at the time, first
became a professional practice
and administrative function
of government in Europe
and the US in particular,
the purpose of planning was
to control urban development
in the interests
of the common good,
by imposing a modest
amount of order,
and providing infrastructural
support to direct and encourage
private and usually
speculative development
of the urban
terrain, and to do so
without challenging
the bourgeois sanctity
of private property.
It was, planning,
and remains a system
that has always left
considerable wiggle
room for unregulated,
unplanned interventions.
In fact, I would say that
even the most rigidly
prescriptive modernist plans,
with their rationalized grids,
their rigorously
zoned land uses,
and robust infrastructures, seem
to not only enable, but also
to accommodate
comfortably a great deal
of informal and unplanned
extralegal intervention
and activity.
In other words, the relationship
between planned and unplanned
urban processes is neither
dichotomous nor oppositional.
Instead, it is one
of entanglement
and interdependency.
It is even symbiotic.
Now in recent years,
and this is what
we will be looking
at in this panel,
that relationship has begun
to morph in ways that we
don't yet fully understand.
The effects of
economic liberalization
and globalization and
new patterns of migration
are seriously challenging
normative planning methods
and destablizing the processes
by which they operate.
In many parts of the
world, as we'll see,
urban processes
are predominantly
informal and unplanned.
And in general, I would say,
in both the global South
and the global
North, one thing that
does seem clear that
is happening now
is that new actors
are determining
the economic and spatial
organization of cities.
In particular,
multinational corporations
are assuming roles that
were previously played
by state and local governments.
Together with
investment banks, they
are financing urban
development around the world.
In the process, planning
is taking a backseat
to private development.
One could call this
the informality
of the powerful, as opposed
to the informal practices
of subsistence and
survival of the powerless.
As a result, the ways in which
cities are being organized,
managed, and built and
the political processes
by which their long term
social agendas are set
are being radically disrupted.
These conditions give rise
to a series of questions that
are the subject of this panel.
They include-- what are the
planned and unplanned dynamics
in cities today?
How do they structure
life and opportunities
for urban dwellers?
How can we act on
that knowledge?
And in particular, how can we
begin to think projectively
about restructuring that
relationship in ways that
might give increased agency
and opportunity to the less
powerful members of society?
Each of our panelists
will speak to these issues
from their own
disciplinary perspectives
and will draw on
their own practices
in a range of different urban
and geographical contexts.
The first speaker, our first
speaker is Edgar Pieterse.
Edgar Pieterse is an
urban scholar and writer
who holds the South African
Research chair in Urban Policy
at the University of
Cape Town in South Africa
and is the director of the
African Center for Cities.
His research is rooted
in sub-Saharan Africa
and focuses on urban
development, politics,
everyday culture, public's
responsive design,
and adaptive governance systems.
These concerns in
sub-Saharan Africa
will be the focus
of his talk today.
Ana Elvira Velez is an
architect based in Medellin,
Columbia and is a professor
of Urban and Environmental
Processes at [INAUDIBLE]
Universidad [INAUDIBLE] ah--
Columbia.
I tried.
In Medellin, she
has been involved
in the extraordinary
and much celebrated
regeneration of the
city, where she has also
designed collective housing and
public space, about which she
will talk today.
And our third speaker
who is in the ether
is Ricky Burdett, who will be
actually joining us by video,
I believe, and various
other remote means.
He unfortunately
had a conflict that
came up in the very
last minute and was
unable to be here today.
Ricky Burdett is a professor
of Urban Studies at the London
School of Economics,
where he directs
the LSE Cities and the
Urban Age Program in London.
In addition to teaching
and publishing,
he's involved in regeneration
projects across Europe,
and he was chief adviser on
architecture and urbanism
for the London 2012 Olympics
and architectural adviser
to the Mayor of London, who was
Ken Livingston at that time.
And his presentation
today will focus on London
and will draw on
that experience.
So please join me in
welcoming the panelists
and our first speaker,
Edgar Pieterse.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you very much,
Eve, and thank you
to the Radcliffe Institute
for the invitation, hugely
exciting to be here.
And I must confess, I'm
feeling a little out of sorts,
because today has
been incredible.
My brain has been
absolutely blown away.
And I kind of wish that the
talks were slightly less
interesting, so
that I could quickly
do another talk to kind of stay
within the spirit of the day
so far.
So it sort of feels
a little bit odd
that I'm going to
be sort of more
on the practice and the
very concrete planning side.
I'm totally seduced by the
humanities tenure of the talks
so far.
So thank you very much to
my fellow speakers today.
It's been really wonderful.
I need the gizmo, got the gizmo.
Gizmo works, fantastic, as
everything else, by the way.
Some people are so organized.
So I'm going to try and cover
an impossibly complex and highly
nuanced topic in a very
short space of time.
So I'm going to do it
in these three moves.
And in some ways I'm going to
go over fairly familiar ground
for probably a lot of
people in the room in terms
of the informal
nature of urbanization
in the sub-Saharan
African continent.
But in some ways, these trends
and patterns are so stark,
we have to continuously
revisit and re-inhabit
these trends to really
remind ourselves
that the informal
is in fact the norm,
and what we regard as modern
urbanization is something
of a distant mirage
for most urban dwellers
across the continent.
I'll try and point
to what's at stake
in the question of the panel
by very briefly showing you
images of two cities, Cape
Town and Accra in Ghana.
And then conclude my talk with
responding to the provocation
that Eve has put forward around
can we think propositionally
and what form might
that take, and how
do we re-imagine what
planning could become,
if we should do so.
We've heard this
morning in Liz's opening
remarks of the scale and
the sort of dramatic nature
of urbanization.
95% of all urban growth
over the next 35 years
will take place in
Asia and Africa.
The important part
for the African story
is that it's not
just urban growth,
but rural areas are also
growing because of an incredibly
fertile demographic
transition that we are still
caught up in at the moment.
So in some ways, it is always a
conceit and extremely dangerous
to speak about Africa as if it
is a geographical entity that
has coherence.
This is work that I did
with the African Development
Bank and the OACD
two years ago, where
we tried to build a typology
to try and at least begin
to help us think through
the incredible diversity
across the continent.
The detail of this
is not so important.
The last row shows
you the number
of countries that fall
into each of the categories
of the typology.
But if you look at
the fertility numbers,
that's really what I want
to draw your attention to.
Except for the
five countries that
have got a highly
diversified economy,
you're still sitting
with a fertility rate
of about five children
per female in most
of these geographies, and
of course, very, very low
incomes per capita.
The structural element
in the African story,
and that drives a lot of the
informality we're concerned
with, is the labor force.
So in 2010, after a decade
of average GDP growth
of around 6.5%,
we're still at 63%
of the labor force caught
up in what the ILO calls
vulnerable employment.
This is, oddly enough, it's a
different statistical category
to the idea of
informal employment.
I can talk about it
in discussion time.
But if we shift register
and look at informality,
you will see that, from the
selection of African cities
there, which is a gendered
breakdown, that it
is by far the predominant and
the normal condition for how
people--
adult citizens in urban areas--
access economic life
and livelihoods.
However, it is not unique
to sub-Saharan Africa.
It is a condition that, in fact,
is more pronounced in Eastern
South Asia, as you can see
from the data, or South Asia,
from the data there,
but also Latin American
or other geographies
of the global South.
The point, though, that is
important to keep in mind,
because urban
living is expensive,
is that wages are both extremely
low and they're highly erratic.
So it really complicates
the livelihood strategies
people need to deploy to
keep a toehold in the city.
Now what's going on there?
Despite impressive
GDP growth, we're
seeing a very bizarre
phenomenon in Africa
where there's a disconnect
between what we've
come to expect as a kind
of conventional evolution
of economic incorporation.
So there is no industrial
middle being built.
We're going straight from
agricultural economies
into services
dominated economies.
And so if you look at the decade
and a half of high growth,
it is only in the services
sector in sub-Saharan Africa
where any employment
creation happened.
This is a disaster,
because we are
going to treble the labor
force in the next 35 years,
from $460 million people in
the labor force to 1.2 billion.
On the back of a dynamic where
the African region is only 2.5%
of the global economy, so
it has no bargaining power
within the rules of the
game of how globalization
is impacting on the continent.
So unsurprisingly, living in
formerly and living in slums
is a pre-dominant condition
for most urban dwellers
in sub-Saharan Africa,
with significant exceptions
being South Africa and
the North Africa region.
So very briefly, if you
look at how people live,
if you look at how people
work, informality is
the predominant condition.
What that means though, from
a planning and a policy point
of view, is that it translates
into a real fiscal problem,
because we've got a
very small tax base
as a result of this condition.
So if you don't have
a revenue stream,
where do you amass
the resources to begin
to respond to the physical
manifestation of this?
And to give you just
a glimpse of what
this means in real terms, we
did, for another piece of work
we did, we tried to work up
what is the per capita spending
power of public authorities
in various African cities?
South Africa has a very
devolved fiscal system,
so you can see it's an
outlier in these comparisons.
But the next city after
Johannesburg and Cape Town
is Addis Ababa, and it is
only $91 per capita per annum.
Right-- per annum-- and
you can see the comparative
to London or to
Seooul to give you
a sense of what the
order of magnitudes
are here in terms of how we
respond to these conditions.
So in this kind of
context, of course,
master planning and
land-use control
take on a distortionary
role, because
of the predominance of informal
systems of livelihood, economy,
and settlement.
And these plans tend to
be incapable of seeing
that in the way that Dilip
spoke about optics of perception
and what can be seen earlier.
Urban regulation is
comprised, of course,
of multiple systems of
control, rule, and mediation.
And there is a very, very
dense and almost impenetrable
logic of coexistence,
symbiosis, and competition.
It is not kind of--
the word, the
notion of symbiosis
might purvey a certain
elegance, but it
is a rough business
of intense power
differentials and conflict.
And it is pretty brutal
in a highly gendered way.
This, of course, means
that in the larger context
of political and
governance reform,
there is this demand
on states to perform
the ritual of formal
systems of democratic rule,
whilst, of course,
the real mechanisms
of running the city, of
running neighborhoods,
is all about dealmaking.
And that's really
beginning to understand
what those practices and
institutional manifestations
of routine dealmaking
is, that I would argue
is at the heart of what
this alternative reading
of planning's
potentialities might be.
Now last year, we convened
everyone in Quito.
And of course, everyone arrived,
and no one could get in.
That's an inside joke for
people who attended the event.
The logistics wasn't
any where near
as efficient as Radcliffe's,
and as a result,
most people spent
half the day queuing
to get access to the event.
But this, of course, was
meant to be the moment where
we were going to confront the
real city as it is emerging
with all of its complexity
around the world
and begin to put forward
a proposition about how
to respond.
The framework, unfortunately,
was kind of the same old,
same old.
The developing story of
basic services and so forth
was seen to be the
ideal outcomes.
The levers for change were
these institutional reforms
at the national level.
Legislation was required.
And the means for
delivering this new vision
was all about territorial
planning and urban design.
And that design question
I can come back to
in the discussion time.
But planning being elevated
as the critical intervention
point to deliver the urban
century, if you will.
Now this wasn't particularly
helpful, because what it fails
to do is to confront this--
what I call the real city.
But then, because
it fails to do that,
it still reduces these
emergent dynamics
in the city to simply being
an expression of dysfunction.
And so, of course,
the remedy then
is political will, sustained
institutional reform,
credible fiscal policies, and
competent urban management,
right?
Who can argue with these things?
So to kind of maybe reflect
on the challenges of what
that might mean
in practice, allow
me to consider two
very quick examples.
So this is a beautiful public
art in performance in Accra.
Unfortunately, I can't talk
about that, because as I said,
I'm rather on this end of
the spectrum this afternoon.
So what we see across
most African cities
is this kind of deal
condition of public policy
that takes on the form
of what I would argue
is slum neglect as this
picture of [INAUDIBLE] shows,
in favor of an obsession with
these new enclave elite forms
of urbanism driven by
private real estate
capital and developers and
facilitated by public, very
scarce, public resources.
The International
New Town Institute
is mapping this phenomena
across the continent.
And this is kind of
the latest update
of the proliferation of these
ambitions and real plans.
If we look at Accra, classic
example of the challenges
we face.
This shows you the
dramatic expansion
in the footprint of the
city in just 25 years,
with very, very little
concomitant investment
in infrastructural capacity.
So in 1990, when you
saw the footprint
as the sort of deep
red area there,
the infrastructural
capacity was merely
for a third of the
population at that point.
And there's been very little
additional expansion to keep up
with the land use encroachment.
So kind of a whole slew
of infrastructural crisis
is the norm.
It's a permanent pattern.
Only a third of the
city's residents
have access to water
borne sanitation.
The three landfill waste
sites were closed down
in 2015 because of
political conflicts.
And as a result,
the water system
got completely contaminated
because of the waste
systems having-- the waste
having no place to go.
And what has happened
in the last while
is a obsession with
delivering this--
[INAUDIBLE] habitat,
because it is
consistent with this vision
of anticipatory planning.
You leave the meso city alone,
and you anticipate where
all that growth is going to go.
And you try and get ready so
that you can, in fact, produce
this alternative urbanism.
I don't have time to go into why
that is profoundly problematic,
but it is just to illustrate
that this is a phenomenon we
see across the continent.
Quickly, in South
Africa, we have
had one of the most ambitious
public housing programs
in the world outside of China.
It's a similar model to
Chile and to Colombia
to some extent, free public
housing through 100% subsidy
that delivers this kind
of modernist stock.
In some ways celebrated,
very important,
an example in Cape Town
is an area called Dunoon.
The dwellings were
delivered in 2000,
and by 2012, that's what it
looked like in real terms.
And what that reflected
was a settlement that
was designed to house
3,000 households,
15,000 people, in fact,
became a settlement
within a decade that was
housing 66,000 people through
in full development,
informal redefinition
of this modernist vision.
Now you can just kind of
extrapolate for yourself
all of the kind of urban
management planning
and so forth.
And this is in a
case where you've
got a $12,000 per
capita country,
modern infrastructure, high
level of planning capacity,
et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera--
and we have no idea how to
respond to this real response
to these plans, so
to conclude them.
So firstly, I think we shouldn't
abandon the idea of planning.
Obviously, it makes no sense.
But maybe we can reanimate or
recast what we mean by planning
and think of building a
different set of vocabularies
and practices, right?
So the spatial framework
idea remains critical.
But I think it can
be redeployed to map
and read the real
city in its fullness,
formal and informal,
makeshift and organized
in terms of its economic,
social, cultural,
and ecological dynamics.
And we see very few
examples of this kind
of spatial representation
pretty much, anyway.
Infrastructure is obviously key.
But to think of
infrastructure, again--
and I was so struck by
Dilip's incredibly evocative,
real representation
of flows and patterns
that helps us to see
very differently.
And it's kind of a really
exploded example of what
I had as a notion in my mind.
So it was really inspiring
to see that example, for me,
of what I would regard as this
kind of reading of landscape
and natural and social
and cultural forces.
And very, very importantly, and
planners are hopeless at this,
is building maps
and representations
of institutional dynamics.
Because what you have are these
complex, modern, traditional
gangster, organized
crime, et cetera,
institutional contaminations
that run these places.
And we have no way of reading
that or making sense of it.
And how can we possibly
recalibrate regulation
if we don't have a language
or way of thinking about that.
And finally, planning as
a platform for-- and again
in my work, I'd elaborate
this much further-- this idea
of Action Networks, which are
not formally institutions,
but a network of people
committed to a certain idea
of the adaptive city.
And in the last minute,
I'll conclude with what
this proposition adds up to.
And this is at the core of a
book that will come out later
in the year and further work
over the next few years.
But really, I'm very
interested in the idea
of planning as narrative.
And if we can kind of
think of the adaptive city
as an alternative narrative
that allows us to think,
if you will, these
interdependent
dynamics in the same
breath, so to speak, so
that we don't have to be
totally skeptical of technology.
We can absolutely see
the potential value
of low tech, labor
intensive enablements that
can be imagined and
produced off the back
of new technological
possibilities.
But at the same
time, there's no way
that we insist that we
can accept the conceit
of the smart city idea--
that you've got to put
in the fiber backbone
40 kilometers away
from the real city
so that you can build this
new future utopia that we
saw some intimations
of this morning.
So practically, it boils
down to this double move
that we think about localization
and regional transitions
at the same time.
And there is kind of
a font mistranslation
there, so it's kind of gone
all wobbly in the circles.
And these regional
transitions is really about
the big catalytic
ones that allows
for building fundamentally
qualitatively
different urban dynamics
and forms and patterns
and flows and circulations,
energy mobility, ICT.
But more importantly
institutionally,
if that is done in a strategic,
intelligent, negotiated way,
one can begin to address
the fiscal question.
And in some ways
the most important,
urgent, politically vital
fiscal planning question
is a fiscal question, right?
And of course, none of this
is possible with some kind
of systematic way of learning
and experimenting and so forth.
There's another part
of the argument,
which is about localization,
that I won't get into.
And then just to conclude--
in this gesture of what
an alternative approach
to planning might mean, planning
becomes a narrative device
that can offer credible
account of the real city.
Planning then has the
potential to function
as a deliberative framework,
within which coalitions
of practice are cohered
to design, test and adapt
alternative
infrastructure approaches,
service delivery models and
livelihood strategies that
can forge a new, adaptive
approach to place-making
and cityness.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good afternoon.
I'm very thankful for the
Radcliffe Institute and Liz
and all her team
to having me here.
It's been a pleasure to hear
all these thoughts today.
And I'm almost the last
one, last but not least.
There's another one.
So please bear for
the next 15 minutes.
I've called my presentation
Intermediate Spaces.
And I will be talking
about housing.
Because housing is probably
one of the biggest elements
that build up our
urban cities, and we
will see this in the
context of Medellin.
Social housing in
Columbia is planned either
by the private developer
or the government
by building mass
produced housings
on sites outside of
the city or high rise
buildings in urban areas.
And course, with no
understanding of context
or habits of the inhabitants.
Most of the times,
housing solutions
seem to be concerned with
the problem of quantity
and not of quality.
So let me understand
what does this mean.
Well, this geometric
element called home,
it has an inside, where it
should embrace the diversity
of the human being.
And towards the outside, it
should preserve the identity
of the context, proposing new
textures, new places to live
by understanding three issues.
The first one, basically,
is landscape textures.
And we live in a tropical
landscape where mountains are
huge, vegetation is dense,
water, rain is abundant,
and sun is strong,
Therefore, it is
important to live consequently
with our surroundings.
The second idea is
how do we dwell?
Popular habits create
architectural elements.
We need to understand the
different architectural
elements that identify
a particular community.
For example, in our Andean
[INAUDIBLE] mountains,
tropic landscape, life
happens between the inside
and the outside.
Somehow, somebody was
telling us this morning.
I mean, there's no barriers
of inside and outside.
So this is an important
element in our daily life.
We have balconies,
terraces, stairways
where people interact.
And this is very important.
And thus this creates
intermediate and collective
areas.
So solving a housing problem
cannot be the creation
of an interior space
to accommodate people.
What is important is to build
up a sequence of threshold
between the most
public space, which
is the streets, the plazas, and
the private space of our homes.
So the design of these different
housing units cannot be solved
by designing the unit itself.
An additional area, which I
called intermediate space,
is an additional and inseparable
part of the solution.
We find eaves of roofs,
corridors, balconies, terraces,
stairs, bridges and
aerial walkways.
All of these spaces
contribute to the building
of sustainable
communities and become
the texture of our landscape.
In this brief
conversation, I aim
to explore ways in
which design can
influence housing
typologies, enabling
the unplanned to happen.
These design issues
are capable of hosting
the rituals of collective
and individual life
experiences in housing schemes
in the city of Medellin
and the region of Antioquia.
So we will see three cases.
Two of the cases in
the city of Medellin.
One in the periphery and the
borders and the outskirts,
one in downtown, and
the other in the region.
Because region is becoming
a very important issue
when we talk about
our territory.
And in the three cases, we
will see different timeline
regulations, different
actors, and of course,
how this unplanned
situation of inhabitants
take into understanding
this new place
and take an appropriation of it.
So this is the city of Medellin.
It is a city of 3 and
1/2 million inhabitants
where mountains are quite high.
They rise around 1,000 meters.
And we will see two
projects in this area.
The first one is Canaveral.
This is a project
developed before the turn
of the century in 1998.
And it consists of 150 units.
And it is in the
outskirts of the city,
because this is where
housing, social housing was
built due to the land value.
But the geography becomes
the main tool of design.
We have very steep slopes.
And it overlooks the
whole of the city.
So the question here when
we were designing was,
how can we design
the idea of a home
when we had to
develop three houses
in the same plot of land?
So this was the answer
we wanted to look for.
So using the
topography as a tool,
we designed a plot
of land of six
by 12, which would contain
three independent houses.
But each house would have
an access from the walkway.
So we would have a first
block, a first house, Number A,
accessing from the
lower block walkway.
The second house entering from
the upper walkway, and then
the third one as well.
So this building of three houses
would build up the whole row
system of these streets,
which would run along
the contours of the geography,
allowing that each house would
have access from the street.
So this is a concept of house
and not of an apartment.
So this was very important
when you understand
what people want when they
become to live together,
and especially to a
segment of middle class
or lower class in an area
which is up in the mountains,
up in the hills.
And when you understand that
these different elements,
stairways, patios, and
terraces become incorporated
as part of the
solution to propose
those intermediate
thresholds between the inside
and the outside and
that become areas
where people in the family
start to inhabit before they
come to the outside.
So these are the elements of the
process of planning, which try
to incorporate the unplanning.
The second project we're
going to see is in downtown.
And this is important, because
there is a shift in regulation.
And it wants that
housing does not
be in the outskirts of
the city, but inside.
And this is because the
government lowers taxes
for the constructors
so that they
can start to build in downtown.
So this is the case of La Playa.
And it is in the downtown area.
This is a block of
80 by 80 meters.
And we would have to
develop 254 units.
And when we got that question of
254 all living in this square,
we thought how do we
rethink the idea of density,
and how do we think rethink
the idea of flexibility--
where we want each person
to have their own apartment
and it had to be different,
so that this unplanning
process would start to happen?
So we designed,
firstly, by the units,
by the most intimate space.
So it is a definite element.
Its a rectangular element
by five by 10.6 meters,
containing a battery of services
and a single [INAUDIBLE] space,
with four identical windows
allowing natural light
and ventilation
for future rooms.
The walls of the
unit are structural
and are the finished
appearance of the exterior
and the interior.
What we realized,
what was important,
was that we would give more
area, but less finished.
Because we know that investment
will happen in the inside,
and never in the outside.
So this was very
important in the shift
of planning that the design
decisions and perfect decisions
were in the outside, and not
in the inside of the home.
So this allowed for
an initial investment
of an unfinished unit, allowing
the highest possible surface
of 52 square meters
plus a balcony, which
would be finished
according to the needs
of the economic possibilities
of the users, unplanned.
So how do we build
up this complex?
First, we have a basic unit.
Four units compose
the service core,
which has an opening, the main
one and a second one allowing
a crossing point
on the first floor.
Four service cores will
build up the first strip,
the second strip,
the third strip.
Then you have 12 independent
vertical circulations,
all going up with a system
of pedestrian walkways.
And this, all together,
will build up 254 units,
but in 12 independent buildings.
And this was very
important as a concept,
because we could
have planned it up,
but we decided to
put it the other way.
And in the horizontal
system, we allowed
that four different
buildings would
appear instead of having one, or
three different ones going up.
So this was very important.
So our bet was the outer
skin and the relationship
to the public real and
all invariable elements
as walkways, common
areas, stairways
will dignify the intimate
life of inhabitants.
This basic decision start to
transform the surrounding,
a new urban park with
the Museum of la Memoria
was developed later on by the
government in the open areas
just adjacent to it.
The opened walkways,
pedestrian walkways
are the extension of the
activities of the house.
A neighborhood seems to
arise, where children are
going to play in the outside.
And this photograph
really brings me
the idea of
neighborhood, where you
see children and people looking
out, being part of the city.
And this is very
important for us.
And finally, each unit
inside has a unique family.
Each one building
their own home,
allowing for the unplanned
of the process to happen.
And now we will go to
the state of Antioquia.
During the years
of 2012 and 2015,
I was consultant for
VIVA, [INAUDIBLE] Housing
Corporation, designing rural
and urban social housing
for the region under
a program which
is VIP, which means housing
for priority families, which
was 100% subsidized which
is a program of free housing
for people.
And this is a town of Salgar,
southwest of Medellin.
And it is a very long
and narrow valley
with a creek in the middle
called the Liboriana.
And it has a [INAUDIBLE] region,
which has slopes going up
from both sides.
And two years ago, due to
heavy and continuous rains,
as we've been hearing
the last session,
we had a big overflow
of the Liboriana Creek,
affecting and destroying
384 homes and 17 bridges.
In response to this, there
was a reconstruction project
built between a partnership
of the public, the private,
and several foundations, as
well with all the community, all
the families to
build up their homes.
This process took two
years to take place.
But what was very important
was the definition
of where along this very
narrow and long valley
to find the appropriate sites.
So two sites were
detected inside of Salgar.
And the third one, which
is this one to the left,
is in the rural area.
But I'll talk about the middle
one, which is La Habana.
The site had an
irregular geometry,
has a small plateau,
base of a steep mountain
on the upper side, and behind
a row of existing one level
houses, and then next to a
recently built sports facility.
It then descends
with a steep slope
towards the main road at
the bottom of the side
and to the creek
to the far right.
If the plan was to
build, then, 42 houses,
the question we
asked ourselves again
was how can we give the
idea of entering a home
with this idea of a street?
And the second thing we
wanted to try to answer
was what was the appropriate
density for a place where
we had to reconnect
people who had a tragedy
and were coming to
a new neighborhood?
So this was kind of how
do we address this idea.
And to address this we
designed a project made--
uh oh-- OK.
The one before, we saw
three strips of buildings.
But each strip of
building was designed
by a unit called the Gallery.
So if the inside was developed
with the regulations that
were asked by government, we bet
on proposing a collective area
which is at the
outside, which was
a common pedestrian
street or a balcony
or a porch which would
allow this interaction
of the old neighborhood with
a new neighborhood to happen.
So planning would
happen with the families
to understand how
their belongings would
come into their homes.
So that was planned,
that took place.
But what was important
was the outside,
because we gave this kind of
porch with a little bench.
But by allowing this bench,
concrete bench to appear,
it allowed people to use the
space as they really wanted.
And identity happened.
So you see chairs.
You see vegetation.
You see afternoon talk.
You see children playing,
or they are looking after,
like this was a huge crib,
people observing, looking down.
And this is our bet.
I mean, we want to build
up communities where people
interact with the building.
So we plan to a certain point,
but then it is important
that the unplanned, but we
know it's part of the process,
takes place.
So these are the buildings
in the situation today,
looking down into the valley.
But we consider that
it is from the inside
that we have to
plan the context.
I mean, we work both
scales, but it is important
this relationship from
one side to the other.
So we have seen three cases of
planned social housing schemes
where design can influence
housing typologies enabling
the unplanned to take
place by an appropriation
of the private space, or
beyond, with local identity
and with human experiences.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- It's Ricky.
- Ricky, welcome.
- All right.
Good evening to everybody.
And I hope you can
hear me, and apologies
for not being with you.
Can you hear me?
- Can you hear us?
- Yes.
- Good.
[LAUGHTER]
- OK.
So what I want to
do in my time is
to respond to Eve's very
interesting introduction
about the status of
planning and also
pick up on some of the issues
that both Edgar and Ana
Elvira have talked about--
Edgar focusing
importantly on the aspect
of institutional dynamics
and Ana Elvira fundamentally
talking about
design and quality.
And what I want to do is talk
about both of these aspects
and how planning should
and can, and Eve,
I want to be optimistic here,
actually bring both together.
And I want to do this through
the examples in London.
Next slide.
As Edgar has already
described, it's
impossible to talk about
one aspect of planning.
It's also impossible to talk
about one aspect of a city.
My city, London, is a
city with an average GDP
of $50,000 a year.
And we saw from Edgar's
statistics, that $15,000 a year
are invested in infrastructure.
It's a city which has 500 banks
and international headquarters.
But the next slide also shows
another aspect of London.
It's actually a low density,
nearly bucolic city.
But if you look very
carefully at the skyline which
is emerging from this
image, you can feel
the tensions of that growth.
And it's exactly
here that planning
can intervene in a useful way.
Next.
But unlike sub-Saharan
Africa, and to a degree
unlike Medellin, London is an
old, creaky, difficult, mature
city.
And if you want
to absorb growth--
and let's remind
ourselves, those cities
which need and have
growth are lucky, as
opposed to the
opposite, of people
leaving cities and leaving
because they have no jobs--
if we want to absorb growth
in a city like London,
we have to absorb
it within existing
spaces like the one we
see represented here,
or the next slide.
I want to talk in fact about
two projects which have filled
the gaps of these cities.
And in response to Eve's first
provocation about public sector
and private sector, I
want to nearly conclude
right at the beginning that
private development need not
be negative as long
as it is well-planned.
And public sector by
definition is not positive
unless it's well-planned.
And this is where the adaptive
nature of planning is central.
And the two examples
I want to give
are the Olympic neighborhood
in the east of London,
which is an ongoing
project 100% funded
by the public sector to
the tune of $15 billion
over a long period of time.
And the next, a private
sector development,
100% private, which
is also ongoing
in a more central part of
London, which is being built
by investors and pension funds.
Where Eve, just to respond
to your provocation,
I think actually, well-designed,
high quality public spaces
which are adaptable, whether
it's public or privately funded
can actually respond to
the needs of the city.
Next slide.
If you look at this image
really quite carefully,
and you zoom in, I know it
may be a bit out of focus,
you see one of the most livable
cities in the global north.
It's a part of London, north
London, which actually,
from where you're sitting and
from where I'm sitting, looks
and is a mess.
And I think the provocation
for all of us in this panel,
is how can you actually
design an infrastructure which
allows a degree of messiness?
Eve, you introduced, very
interestingly, the notion
of wiggle room at the beginning.
I think we need to
understand, in our planning,
how to adapt and
allow for wiggle room.
And I think I concur with
Edgar that maybe the best
form of planning is not
to anticipate outcomes,
not to anticipate outcomes.
And what we're
seeing in this image
is maybe something
about that, and I'll
conclude with that in a moment.
Next slide.
There are other
ways of planning.
This is the archetypal
way of planning
a city from the
19th century, which
has served this city well.
Or there's another model, which
is depicted in the next slide,
of a part of Rome, a central
part of Rome, which to a degree
had planning, but an enormous
amount of informal growth.
We could call it that, extremely
beautiful informal growth,
which has reacted and adapted
to the tissue which is there
with high level of
quality of public space.
Next slide.
London, in this
image, is organic.
It's messy.
It's unplanned, and therefore,
it's also extremely fragile,
maybe an issue we can
come back to at the end.
Next slide.
Politics, as Edgar has
told us, is fundamental.
You just can't talk about
planning without understanding
the institutional dynamics.
We happened to have invented,
over the last 16 years,
the concept of a directly
elected mayor in London.
This has been instrumental.
Next slide.
The reality-- you can't
see what's on this slide--
is that's actually
how planning works.
There are many different bodies,
many different institutions.
And Edgar is absolutely right.
We need to understand
those first, whose
voice is being understood?
But you need a
framework to do that.
Next slide.
London happens to be growing.
It's now just
about nine million,
and it will be 10
million by 2030.
Next slide.
But there is a policy in place
which says that London cannot
grow outside its boundary.
That's a very
strong planning act
from the 1940s, which has
imposed a limit, and therefore
reduced sprawl, I think one
of the most intelligent forms
of planning that I know.
So where do you grow when you
have the need to accommodate
one more million people?
Next slide.
Well, you find the gashes,
the open spaces that you have.
Next slide.
And this has meant that London
is slowly but firmly moving
east, where many of the
ex-industrial spaces are.
Next.
And the London plan, we did
not go into this in detail,
focuses on these two things.
Keep the city within its limits.
You need a powerful political
structure to do that.
But allow and encourage
development along the areas
that you need to--
next-- particularly in areas
which have available land,
like the two examples I'm going
to talk about in the next part
of my talk-- next--
the King's Cross development
and the Olympic quarter, both
located in slightly central
but peripheral areas of London.
Next.
To understand London,
and this is responding
to Edgar's request,
in a good way,
you need to understand
what the real city is.
This map shows in red where
the people who are most
deprived in our city, in this
decade of the 21st century,
are.
And then green
are most affluent.
You can see a split between east
and west and between periphery
and center.
Summarizing it very
quickly, it is the east
that is the most deprived.
If you did this map in
Paris and perhaps in Boston,
you would have a completely
different diagram.
You need to understand
the structure
within you're working before you
employ mechanisms to solve it.
Next.
So our two areas are actually
in some of the most deprived
parts of the city.
Next.
When London, by mistake, won the
Olympics for the 2012 event--
if you remember, New York
was the strongest candidate--
the first decision that was
made, let's put it in an area
where we can do good
things with the $15 billion
of public money.
And let's try and not
make it into a ghetto,
but make it into an
integrated piece of city.
This is exactly what Ana
Elvira has been talking about.
How do you, at the scale,
in her case of housing,
create streets and connections,
so that as the city grows up
around it or as you
integrate it with it,
it does not stand alone
as an isolated ghetto?
Eve, this is the planning
you've been talking
about which is negative.
The one that actually
creates what is on the left
and not what is on the right.
Next.
What happened in the
site of the Olympics,
you can see it there
circled in green,
is to take a site which was a
railway, disused railway land,
surrounded by strong
sense of community,
but literally cut off
from its surroundings.
Next.
That's what it looked like.
And that's where my fridge
and everyone else's fridge
in London was dumped
for many, many years.
Cities have back spaces.
How do you foreground
them is the issue.
Next.
It's a place surrounded by
strong migrant communities
from different
parts of the world
and different
ethnicities, very rich.
Next.
And there was a desire
by the government
to use this policy to try and
effectively redistribute wealth
through long term planning.
And time is essential to this.
Next.
So this was the vision.
These are the visions
that we all hate.
It's an image of a sort
of perfect seamless
community fixed in time.
What I want to say
in the few minutes
that I talk about this
and the next project,
is how can you try
and actually work
against the grain of fixity of
the image that you see here?
Next slide.
Well, this is an image of fridge
mountain during the Olympics
itself, a nice park with
a stadium behind it.
Next.
But you'll also
remember the slide
that I showed you that
the site was totally
isolated from its surrounding.
It was a railway goods yard.
So the first chunk, in fact,
roughly a billion dollars
of the money from
central government
was used to create 37
bridges, links, connections
between this empty hole
and the rest of the city.
In other words,
it's the beginning
of that adaptive process that
we've been talking about.
Next.
The design I don't need to
go into in great detail.
The most important thing about
this slide is that I hope,
and it's not because it's
out of focus, but because
of design intent, you
can't see the edges
of where the site begins or
the Olympic site and the rest.
It sort of looks like
the rest of messy London.
Next.
And significantly,
the way in which
the planning was conceived was
not to do it all in one go,
because that is unrealistic,
not to start at one end
and go down to the
bottom, not to start
where the value is near
the railway stations
and then build out.
But to actually do it in a
piecemeal way, which reflects,
again, the reality,
as Edgar called it,
of the processes of city change.
Next.
This is how many
parts of London have
grown for the last 200 years.
Next.
This is what the athletes'
village was like.
Sorry, this is what was
the athletes' village
and the picture taken
yesterday in what
is part of the residential
community, which is roughly 50%
affordable and 50% market
rental, known as the East
Village.
Next.
There are schools.
There are institutions
at the heart of it
which serve not just the
new residents, but those
in the surroundings.
Next.
There are 6,000 jobs created in
what used to be the [INAUDIBLE]
great media hall.
Next.
Even the great swimming pool
designed by the late great Zaha
Hadid, next, which
was symbolic and had
17,000 seats during the games--
next-- is now where,
for $5, anyone
who lives in the
neighborhood can actually use
as a literally community pool.
Next.
The notion of actually creating
a park at the middle of it
has actually become
a resource, not just
for those who live there,
because you don't know
where the edge is, but for
the much wider surrounding
community.
Next.
But things change.
And Eve has raised this.
The ability to adapt,
to be resilient
is absolutely central.
What you see here is the
canal on the right-hand side,
the swimming complex, and
then a sort of large park
area with water on both sides.
No one really knew what
to do with this area.
And actually what has happened
over the last three or four
years, is that as the area,
the whole area of Stratford,
has become more central
in the mind of Londoners
and investors, next, a whole
series of organizations
who would have never
touched this part of London,
because of its distance
and its deprivation--
the Victorian Albert Museum,
the University of the Arts,
University College London, and
in fact, even the Smithsonian--
next, are now actually
building new premises
which will be part of a new
cultural quarter in a part
of London that had no culture.
Next.
The most important
point I'm making here
is that not
everything that we see
happening in this part
of London was actually
planned or understood.
This is why I would
repeat and endorse
the notion of not
anticipating outcomes,
but to just provide a framework
which can adapt to them.
Next.
Let's look, very briefly,
in the last four minutes
of my talk at the opposite
end of the scale in terms
of investment.
But perhaps similar
conclusions as to what
might work or not work in
providing this wiggle room,
in dealing with a
fragile urban fabric,
particularly in
areas of deprivation.
Next.
In an area which has two of
the best connected railway
stations, certainly
in England, if not
in Europe, King's
Cross on the right
and St. Pancras on the
left, is another gash,
another gaping hole
of railway goods yard.
Think of Hudson Yards in
New York as the equivalent.
And keep that image of
Hudson Yards in your mind
for a moment, all of you who
know what is being built there.
This was an image
only in the year 2000.
Next.
This is an image of what's
actually going to be built,
and much of it is actually
more or less realized,
with homes, jobs, and
other facilities which
I'm going to talk about.
Next.
It's a project
which has benefited
from massive public transport
investment, that is true.
But the 4 billion
dollars comes from
Australian and Canadian pension
funds behind a front line
developer.
I think we need to reflect how
those sorts of actors, as you
called it, Eve, can
actually benefit
the structure of the city
rather than necessarily create
yet another ghetto.
Next.
The way this part of
London was planned
was to pick up the fine mix that
you see in surrounding areas.
Next.
The idea was, yes, it's private.
But make it as connected
and as public as possible.
Work on the streets
and the integration
that we've heard of before.
Next.
Three diagrams to show
you what was important--
take every possible connection,
every possible street
that comes into the
site, and extend it
into the neighborhood.
That's a very strong
starting point
for creating a
flexible framework.
Next.
Put on the ground
floor the mix of
uses that you find
elsewhere in London,
and don't just concentrate
them at the valuable end.
What you see here in
the different colors
are everything from
museum, housing,
to places for work,
which were not expected
in this part of London.
Next.
And the public
space, which you see
colored in brown
effectively here,
is the one cohesive
element which
was fixed a few years ago.
The uses of most of
the building have come
in as the project has evolved.
Next.
Public space is
one example here.
The buildings around
them, some are
very good, some
are mediocre, seem
to work well for the grain
of this part of London.
Next.
But most importantly,
no one knew
what to do with that fantastic
building in the background
called the Granary Building.
And the University of the
Arts, next, moved into there,
bringing-- next--
5,000 students,
creative arts students,
who make things, who are
there until three or four
or five o'clock in the morning,
moved in as the first tenants,
with I'm sure, some
very, very good deal
when it came to the rent.
But the point is that there
was a flexible enough structure
to allow that.
Next.
As a result of that, Google
decided to move all--
all its European headquarters
into the site right next door.
You could say
inspired by the fact
that there are students
and creative types
in the neighborhood, bringing,
in the next few years,
8,000 employees to this
area that you really
wouldn't have thought
would have attracted them.
The design that you see
there is now being changed,
next, a little
bit, unfortunately,
inspired by Californian
notions of campus architecture.
We're going to see what it looks
like in the next few months.
Next.
But interestingly,
this has also meant
that Europe's largest medical
research facility has suddenly
found its location there
next to the British Library.
Next.
Basically, I want to conclude by
saying that this project, which
didn't have a name except
that it was a development,
is now seen as London's
knowledge quarter.
I know it's another brand.
It's another name.
But behind that,
as I said, there
are 13,000 homes, of
which 50% are affordable,
right in the middle
of London, where
there is better access
to jobs than you
could have anywhere else.
Next.
I showed you this image right
at the beginning, of Camden.
It's a city which
has not been designed
top down like Barcelona,
perhaps not even
like the Manhattan grid.
But it has similar
characteristics
of adaptability.
The point is, and this is
where I want to conclude,
Eve, is that these adaptions
can be very fragile.
You can take exactly the sort
of sites I've been talking about
and turn them into fortresses.
That's what's happening to
most of the new developments
in the African city.
That's what Edgar has
actually described to us.
And that's why there's such a
strong anti-planning approach
in many of the words
and many of the concepts
that you've been talking about.
Next.
I would argue-- next, please--
I would argue that in the end,
this planning model of London
has one, at least allows us to
accept that cities are fragile.
But that you can be
agile within that
and provide a sort of resilient
framework, whereby planning
returns in the 21st
century as something which
is positive and applies not just
to the unique and rich cultures
that we happen to belong
to in the global north,
but can be applied and
adapted as we saw in Medellin,
and I think need to
happen in Africa,
but we're a very, very
long way away from that.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Ricky.
Can you hear me?
- I can hear you, and I
think, I might even see you,
or you might even
see me, I don't know.
- Hi.
This was wonderful.
Three really fascinating
presentations.
And each one actually very
different in terms of context
obviously, also in terms of
scales and in terms of actors.
And yet there are
common themes that
run through them that I would
like to pick up and talk about.
Edgar, I think just in terms of
taking the scaler issue here,
that you're looking--
what we're getting here is
the systemic scale and sort
of what the larger
systems that actually
structure society, that
include structuring
the urban environment.
And I think that one other
thing I wanted to say in here
is that there also seems
to be one other theme that
is emerging in all
of these three--
or emerged in all of
these three talks,
and that is what we can learn
from the informal, actually,
and how we can learn from it.
And one of the things I thought
that was very interesting
about Edgar's presentation
was that, as he put it,
the informal and the unplanned
processes and practices
are constitutive in
both senses of the word,
in meaning that
they're composed of
and they also have the power
to give organized existence
to something, that they
are in constitutive
of human settlements, but also
of broader economic activity.
And that that is,
as I understand
it, a very important
thing if one
is going to think about
intervening in the city,
that it is an environment
that incorporates place making
and work.
And that the planning
potential of informal practices
is this creation of employment.
And the issue, it seems to me
that you were talking about,
is the scaling up.
How does one scale that up
from this sort of small scale
interventions to
institutionalize
these processes and
these relationships
while still retaining
their flexibility.
And Ana, the scale of your
project was much smaller,
and actually-- but
what's so interesting
about it is that the
same issues pertain
at these different
scalar levels.
So this is about social housing
in the city and the region,
public and private projects
that open up a relationship
or that have an
open relationship
between the planned
and the unplanned,
and particularly, you identified
interstitial spaces, these sort
of mediating
spaces, thresholds I
think you called them, where the
public and the private overlap.
That provide spaces of
opportunity, that these are,
and if we're thinking
now in planning terms--
that planning is about the
public and the private--
that it's these spaces
where these things become
blurred that some
form of communal space
has the potential to develop.
And Ricky, fascinating projects,
publicly and privately funded.
I think that your model
of fragility, agility,
and resilience is
something that applies
to all of these projects.
And I think that
one of the things
that I found interesting
in some of the terminology
that you used, that
flexible spatial frameworks,
and I think you used
that term, allows
them to be shaped and
adapted and reappropriated
through relatively
informal processes.
And so what's happening here
is that formal and informal
are becoming very relative.
And so that the
boundaries between them
are actually very fluid.
And I think that there's also
a common vocabulary here,
that the techniques and
processes are of appropriation.
These are words that
everybody used, I think--
adaptation, flexibility,
agility, resilience, hybridity.
And there are a couple
of things that I
think are interesting
out of that
that I'd like to pose as
a question or something
to talk about here.
And that is this--
fundamentally, what
we've been looking at
is this relationship between
the planned and the unplanned.
And while these
informal processes
have tremendous
potential, everyone
has mentioned the
importance of having a plan,
that you need to have a plan.
You need to have a
plan in the sense
that you need to have a concept
of what you're trying to do,
of what your objective is.
And there has to be some
kind of agenda there.
And so I wanted to throw
that out and see if you
wanted to comment on that.
- You want to start?
- You can start.
- Well, Eve, I think it's
important to understand, well,
as I see it, that plan, the
concept of having a plan,
is also a concept of defining a
physical definition of a space.
And that's how I understand it.
And the unplanned for
me is the people who
come inside and interaction.
So that's how I understand
planned and unplanned.
Because you have a
definition of how do
you want uses, spaces,
whatever you want to call it.
But it is important to
understand that people come in.
And it is the interaction
of that planned idea,
how people are able to
develop their rituals,
their understanding.
And as Richard or
Ricky was saying,
it allows that this
framework of the planned
has to allow this
unplanned of the social.
So I understand it as a
hardware and a software.
And they do have to come
together all the time.
You cannot think of them as
separate elements definitely.
I don't know if that helps.
- So slightly, yeah--
so I guess the
idea of the plan--
and as I suggested, to connect
it to the notion of narrative,
and maybe that also will
see a useful connect back
to the broader
thematic of why it
is helpful to have
the humanities
and the social sciences talk--
is that, of course, the plan
goes to the heart of knowledge
and control, right?
And so in a lot of the
context that I'm interested in
and that I work on,
it is the absence
of the circulation of
knowledge or the deployment
of certain kinds
of knowledges that
allows a very, very small
elite to extract rents and make
crazy profits and
essentially render
the very same plan redundant.
So there's a
politics of knowledge
that I think is very important.
So I'm very attracted to the
idea of the plan in that it
allows us to bring transparency
to a set of processes
that unfold that structures
the deployment of capital.
And I mean capital
in the broad sense,
both the meager
savings of the street
trader and the
strategic opportunity
that the pension
fund has spotted
in whatever new development
is taking place.
And so I think that
it is important,
if we continue to invoke
the idea of the plan,
that it provides a rationale and
a democratic discipline for it
to effect transparency,
which then
enables a different kind of
conversation to take place.
Secondly, because
of precisely the way
in which the city is built and
reproduced by the sheer effort
and sweat and aspirations
of its inhabitants,
there's an
opportunity for people
to tell their own stories.
I was really drawn to
the beautiful drawings
that you reflected of how people
imagined they could inhabit
these spaces as a part of
the process of imagining
how the design could get
that calibration right--
between the
structuring framework
and leaving enough space for a
culturally infused inhabitation
to make home and to make place.
So I think that
this idea that there
are a multiplicity of
registers within which we plan,
in which we build narrative,
and in which we can, indeed,
contest certain god
given narratives of how
the city should be built,
or where investments should
go first, is as
urgent politically
and economically as
it could ever be.
And just the last
point I want to make
is that one of the things
that I struggle with
is this really difficult,
often unintended,
confluence of interest
between the need for obscurity
on the side of the
dealmakers, the big deal
makers, and the
effect of a really
staid, top down, inwardly
looking bureaucratic mentality
that treats the plan
as an artifact that
is the only guarantor of
public autonomy or authority.
Even though it doesn't
get implemented--
but the amount of effort
bureaucratic planners
spend in many African
local authorities
and so forth to
perfect the plan--
they know it's not
going to be used.
But it's kind of the only
vestige of an attachment
to authority that they have--
serves the dealmakers
very, very well, right?
And so there's also
a need, I think,
to kind of radicalize
the idea of the plan,
so that we can render strange
these incredibly dysfunctional
practices.
I don't know if that--
- But I think,
Edgar, that can only
happen if the actors involved
in shaping those plans,
in commissioning those plans,
in designing those plans,
have in their mind set a
sort of interdisciplinarity
already in their head.
What I'm getting
at is most planning
is in the hands of
professions which value
technique over social value.
And I guess I am
getting at engineers,
planners, who work in silos,
do not attend conferences
like this one, and
where you don't
get architects and engineers
talking to policy makers
and sociologists, shall we say.
I think this is an
important point,
because many plans, and
particularly in African
cities, are predicated on things
like we must improve access
to mobility or
transport, full stop.
It's a virtue and
an end in itself.
If you look at the London plan
that I showed you very briefly,
and if you remember
the inequality,
the deprivation
map, the London plan
can be summarized
in one sentence--
To take the red areas,
the deprived areas,
and redistribute them
across the city and not
have an area of concentration.
Therefore all the technical
investments, transport,
broadband, better schools,
universities, education,
are deployed as part
of that project.
And I think that
that is something
that would be interesting
to perhaps speculate on,
whether that's
possible outside--
let's call it some mature,
elite government, examples
like the ones I've
been talking about.
But then I want to throw in
perhaps a slight critique
of democratic processes
that we have inherited.
The UK has had a planning
process for the last 100
plus years.
The result of that
is that the voice
of people living at the borough
level, the local authority
level, is dominant when it comes
to giving planning permission.
It's not community voiced,
but it's slightly above that.
It's at the unit of
two, 300,000 people.
Both the Olympic site
and the King's Cross site
cut across different
political boundaries.
So you have different zones with
different political allegiances
and different
leaders and all that.
The only way the Olympic
project happened,
and only three or
four years have
passed since we
had the games, was
that the mayor put a red line
around the whole neighborhood
and called it a Mayoral
Development Corporation,
literally took the
power of decision
making away from the boroughs.
In the most bizarre
way, that meant
that some of the bigger issues
of what London was about,
as opposed to the
parochial issues of which
small community, have prevailed.
And we've ended up with
the sort of project
that we're talking about.
Now that is a
provocation, I realize,
because it's really
going against the grain
that small is beautiful
and every decision
needs to be taken
at the lower level.
I think you need some of
that big picture thinking,
and big picture
institutional reframing
to deliver some of these ideas.
- I think that's
very interesting.
Just a side note here,
one of the things
that we've discovered
in the research
that we were doing in the Mellon
Initiative on four cities,
we've been looking at Berlin,
Boston, Mumbai, and Istanbul,
is that, actually, one of the
interesting things about all
these cities is that they
all seem to have a 2030 plan.
They have some
aspirational plan,
that this is what we
want our city to be.
Berlin is an open city that
welcomes migrants, that has
opportunities, that does this.
The Boston plan has similar
kinds of aspirations.
But that is, I
think, a little bit--
of course, that's branding or
whatever you want to call it.
But it's actually
more than that, too.
It's a sense of our
larger sense of the city
as being an aspirational
place, actually.
That you can try,
you have goals,
that there are common goals.
And it's this notion of
the common good again.
It's a romantic idea, perhaps.
But I think that that's
part of this idea
about the importance of the
plan as a narrative device,
actually.
That our city is about this.
Our city is about
sustainability.
Our city is about equity.
Anyhow, I want to open it up
to the audience for questions.
- Hello, I'm a Ben
[? Bolcher, ?] an alum
of the GST here at Harvard.
This is a question for Ricky.
It seems that there is
a very uneven record
of public investment in
Olympic projects historically,
and at producing, and
that public value outcome.
With regard to the
London project,
is the kind of good
public outcome that
is expected an
unintended consequence
or are there structural lessons
to learn for future large scale
projects of other Olympics
elsewhere from the London
example?
- Thank you for the question.
Of course, I'm biased in
answering that question.
There are very, very
different outcomes
to different Olympic projects.
And what we did
in London was very
simply follow the ones that
worked and studied them
very carefully.
And Barcelona clearly, of
the 1992 games of Barcelona,
is a very clear
model, which goes back
to exactly what Eve was saying.
They were not shy about
having a social program.
And the Olympics was a way of
achieving that social program.
So I think, in that sense, we
did very much copy that model.
There were examples
that we could look at,
some of them, for
example, Athens,
which had been recently held,
whereby vast investment had
been made without any notion of
how the different venues would
actually fit within the social,
economic, and cultural fabric
of the city.
And I know this is
dangerous territory,
but the Atlanta and Los
Angeles models of Olympics
are not necessarily
the best examples
of how to look at long
term sustainable commitment
to the future of the city.
If one thinks of what
happens in terms of riots
and elsewhere in Los
Angeles not that many years
after those Olympic games.
I think in terms of using the
London Olympics to do what it's
trying to do, we
can't claim in any way
that it's just the
London Olympics project.
It fits into a much deeper,
longer term thinking
of how government can intervene
going back to Edgar's point
to redistribute wealth and
actually create greater equity
across the surface of the city.
So this was an
example, and I'm told
by a number of serious
economists that the London
School of Economics
so it must be true,
that we accelerated the
regeneration and possible
equalization of London
by around 70 years
as a result of this process.
But it was going
to happen anyway.
- Hello.
My name is Dale Hepler.
I'm an architect here in Boston.
My question is for Edgar.
You used a phrase a couple of
times that I found intriguing.
You were saying
narrative-based planning.
I was hoping you could
explain a little bit more
how narrative
influences planning,
or especially in the range
of talks we've heard today.
- Yeah, so it actually connects
very directly to Eve's point.
So I think that-- and
also some of the points
Ricky has been making.
So we've got to recognize
that there's, of course,
different scales at play.
And we need a different set
of practices and processes
and sense and
institutional sensibilities
at these different scales.
So if we go back to the
earlier panels of today dealing
with climate impacts, crisis of
water management and so forth,
these require, by definition,
a metropolitan regional
perspective.
You can't resolve those
questions one block at a time.
And it is impossible, because
of the sheer complexity
and going back, I guess, to the
big data point this morning,
to in a way have an
inclusive democratic process,
to deliberate on those questions
at the scale of the city
region.
So the tendency towards
these 2030 plans,
2040 plans and so
forth, is a reflection
of trying to construct a
narrative that can deal
with that regional complexity.
And the key word that emerges
typically from those plans
is this idea of
growth management.
And in the last five years,
you combine growth management
with resilience, right?
And then your consultancy
practice will,
you know, good business
for the next 20 years.
So this is where the rub lies.
That, of course, when you
talk about growth management
or resilience,
immediately a whole suite
of stabilized meanings
come to the fore
that are mediated by
consultancy practices.
And I think this is incredibly
dangerous, because people stop
to think, they stop to
really work with the data,
and they stop to
bring to forward
the constitutive conflicts
and conflicts of interest,
both generationally and at
the city-regional scale.
Which is why the London
example is so interesting
is precisely because it
takes a regional perspective
and says that's the
zone of deep deprivation
with cumulative disadvantage.
And at the same
time, when you're
going to pop $50
billion, you've got
to think about three
generations into the future
and who represents
their interests.
So I think that, for me,
the narrative is then
how do we foreground the
tradeoffs and the decisions
and the assumptions
of that narrative?
And for me, the planning
process could, potentially,
if it is curated properly,
could service that
and at least have an
informed public discourse.
So because the issue is not
that that gives you the best
outcome, but it creates
a democratic atmosphere
within which a certain political
leadership is called for.
And that's what we need is
the politicization of planning
and that the right
kinds of pressure points
are applied by a
plurality of interests.
And at the same time, at
the local level, for me
it's very clear.
If I look at a crowd, or I look
at a slum in Cape Town or so,
that people's kind of
social, reproductive needs
are what all of us
aspire to and want--
is our kids in a good
school, not being exposed
to sexual predators, being able
to access good quality food,
have energy security, et cetera.
So this is not rocket science.
We know this.
But the point is that because
of this cumulative process
of exclusion and
social injustice,
it is very complex to
work out where do you
get the resources to intervene
in a dense, if you will,
milieu of compensation.
Where people have
kind of improvised
to do all kinds of things
to get by, but even that,
at the intimate scale, are shot
through with power relations.
So how do we build a way
of opening up those logics
through the voice
and the practices
and the experience of people
who live there, who constitute
that reality, and animate that
in a pedagogic way for them
to imagine other possibilities
and other ways of doing?
And I think we're at a very
interesting cusp, where
if you look at what's happening
in East Africa with micro-grids
and energy systems that is
working off M-Pesa, which
is a mobile phone, a dumb mobile
phone financial system that
is enabling new
micro-grids to be operated
by slum dwellers themselves.
And that's one example.
So the point is that
planning in that context
is about making legible
a narrative people have
of how they get by.
But also, if one animated,
which is the planning
part, in a creative way, one can
build new imaginations of what
that neighborhood could become.
And so narrative, I think,
works at different scales
in different ways.
But you need very different
pedagogic techniques
to build that narrative
and to build it critically.
- Thank you.
- If resiliency also
means pulling back
in the not so far future,
like Miami or Lagos,
or for that matter, London,
as the seas get higher,
you're going to lose some land.
You may not have the
space or the infilling,
like you just explained.
You're going to have to
go somewhere or go up.
What type of
planning is at least
being conceptualized
to try to do--
a Dutch solution only
buys you some time.
If the seas keep
rising as projected,
we have time to plan for that.
But it still means you've
got to go somewhere
with a lot of people
that have been displaced
or a lot of facilities,
such as sewer plants
or what have you,
that are going to be
displaced by this activity.
- I mean, Dilip
is in the audience
so there's no way I'm responding
to that question, right?
So I think that--
and Ricky will have
things to say about this
because the LSE city center runs
an expansive research
program in different cities
on questions of climate
adaptation and resilience.
But just to say very
briefly that, of course,
there are the big events in
terms of the large climate
impacts and the
form of sea level
rise and the consequences.
But, of course, a more critical
and important aspect of that
is the immediate
climate variability,
and the way in
which that impacts,
in a highly disproportionate
way on the most
vulnerable in the city, which,
of course, are the poorest
people who live in
the most precarious
environmentally sensitive areas.
So I think it is very
important, and it's
the only point I will make, that
we don't slip into a discourse
that this is something that
allows for anticipatory
planning over the long term.
The devastation
is happening now.
Ricky?
- Well, I mean,
again, there are so
many other people who know
more about this than I do,
and probably in the room.
And the difference between
mitigation and adaptation
is central to this very
intelligent question.
All I would say is
that controlling land,
not just in terms
of speculation,
which is what Eve had
said at the beginning,
but in terms of where land
is most risky, stopping
informal development happening
exactly in those areas
which is most risky--
think of Jakarta, think of
Lagos, think of elsewhere--
requires a degree
of political control
which unfortunately is missing
in many of these areas.
Referring to the point that
Edgar has made about our work
is certainly an intelligent
and well-planned form
of high density development must
be the answer to this, because
of the critical mass and
also the structural solidity.
But also being pragmatic
and realistic about it.
The best example I know
is the whole redevelopment
of the waterfront area in
Hamburg called HafenCity,
where basically it's
acknowledged that there
will be a five meter devastating
flood at some point in time.
And therefore the
city has actually
been designed in such a way
that only garages, depots,
and a degree of retail is in
that lower level, landscaping
and much else.
Actually, some of it
incredibly beautiful.
But it doesn't stop the
city from actually expanding
into the port area and making
it a very important addition
to the city.
But taking completely
in mind that you
don't want to expose
people, and particularly
those who are most at risk
as Edgar has described.
In the case of
London, very simply,
if you went a bit, two
miles further east of where
the Olympics are, you would
actually be within a flood zone
and different regulations apply
to how housing is actually
built.
- I think that our time is up.
We can continue conversations
at the reception.
I think there's a
reception following.
And I want to
thank our speakers,
and I want to
thank our audience.
And I want to thank
Radcliffe and Liz Cohen,
again, for hosting this event.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- I'd just like to make a
few very brief remarks just
to close things out.
I think this conference
has proved its own title,
Intersections-- that we require
many different disciplines
and voices and
perspectives in order
to work on the complex
phenomenon of urbanism.
When we first
started this project,
Eve drew my attention
to a small book
written by the French Marxist
sociologist and philosopher
Henri Lefebvre.
His much better known work,
The Production of Space
is one of my faves, but I
hadn't known about his shorter
book, The Urban Revolution.
And in that book which he
wrote nearly 50 years ago
he made a distinction
between the urban phenomenon
and the city that I think has
even greater resonance for us
today.
According to the
Lefebvre, the city
is a term that
attempts to designate
a clearly defined, definitive
object, a scientific object.
Whereas the urban, he
says, is pure form--
a place of encounter,
assembly and simultaneity.
This form has no
content, but is a center
of attraction and life.
The urban is neither
an object, substance,
nor a subject, consciousness.
The urban phenomenon is
made manifest as movement.
So that's Lefebvre, way
back, almost 50 years ago.
I hope this conference has
helped us to think together
about how to approach
this dynamic moving
target of urbanism in the global
age, issues in which we all
have a stake.
Before we close, I would like
to thank all of our speakers.
I would like to thank
the Academic Venture
staff, especially to Jessica
Vickland, the Director
of Events at
Radcliffe, who handled
all of the logistics for
the entire conference,
and the entire events and
facilities teams at Radcliffe.
I'd like to thank
Becky Wasserman, who's
the Executive Director
of Academic Ventures, who
did so much to
support us in putting
this conference into place.
And then, last and
certainly not least,
I'd like to thank Dean Liz
Cohen for the tremendous support
that she gave to the
Mellon Initiative
when it first began
four years ago.
It's been a very rich valuable
experience for all of us.
And I think this conference was
the right culminating event.
So thank you for being with us.
- Now my turn to
ask you to help me
thank the organizers, who
did a really terrific job.